hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and today we're
gonna take some of that data that we
moved from sequel server into my sequel
via the WordPress API and we're going to
take that data now out of WordPress with
graph QL into our react next j/s
applications so first thing we have to
do well I already did the first thing
before the stream so I just installed
the latest version of the WP graph QL
plug-in onto WordPress so just a quick
recap of how I did that it's in case
you're you know following along or what
do you use this for your own project I
just went to the WP graph QL I don't
think I have it up anymore I went to
their github page and then I went to
releases I guess I can bring it up just
to show y'all
there we go okay so when you go we know
to get up repo you can check the
releases so I clicked on releases I
downloaded this zip file of the latest
release and then I just went into the
plugins add new plug-in upload and then
I uploaded that zip file alright that's
it it's as simple as that
activated that after you do that you do
need to flush your what do they call it
your permalinks so the way I do it is I
just click on one of these buttons and
then I click back I save it and I click
on another one of those buttons and that
flushes it for me they may be a better
way to do that but I don't know but if
you skip that step it's not gonna work
you're not gonna get any data from that
graph qo endpoint but assuming you did
that now if you just type in your so
this is graph graph eql I'm not sure how
to pronounce that but you can get it as
a Chrome extension you just put in your
URL which in our case now is it's just
an IP address and then put graph QL at
the end a slash graph key well and you
should be able to get some data so right
now I'm just testing it and I'm grabbing
the IDS of all of our posts okay so that
part is pretty easy but here's the the
problem that we had it's not really a
problem it's just an extra step we have
to do so that post type that we made in
our last stream faculty I'm gonna try to
get data from that and it says it can't
find the field faculty all right so we
have to add something else to our plugin
our custom post types plug-in to make
this work so here's our faculty custom
post type and you can see down here we
say show and rest in the rest api and
that's how we got it to show up
obviously in our REST API but
what we need to do now is we need to get
it to show up in graph QL as well so
we're gonna go graph oops sorry show in
graph QL actually let me start my let me
start my Pomodoro timer since we're kind
of getting into it right away okay I
just checked the latch at hey everybody
and Brooks says is it graph graph e cool
like graphical but cooler I don't know
that maybe that's how you pronounce it I
just I've never heard it always just
seen it alright here we go let's start
our Pomodoro timer we're going to get
into Pomodoro sessions today I have a
Christmas party for my department here
in about an hour and a half a little
less than an hour and a half so we'll
see what we much we can get done
let's see graph
kilo graph kilo and we also hoops a
skipped as for label
we need to add a label as well
I think we do 30p graphical poser custom
feels I'm gonna try to get away with not
adding the label so I have some
documentation open here this is from the
graph graph WP graph QL wiki and it's
saying to put in this label but I I
don't know that much about this but it
seems to me like I might not have to add
this label so I'm gonna try to get away
without it and see if it works all right
so let me all right so we're gonna show
in graph QL and then we're gonna do this
little arrow thing I'm not sure what
they call that in in PHP but looks like
an arrow function to me coming from
JavaScript land so we're gonna say true
and then graph qo single name we're
gonna give it faculty and then we're
just gonna say faculty again I guess if
I really wanted to for singular we could
do like faculty member but I think it'll
be fine
so plural plural name okay so let's see
public sure we make sure I have
everything the way it should be okay
that looks good and then also if we want
to get that custom taxonomy working we
need to add some things in there as well
so right now our custom taxonomy we have
said show and rest so we need to do
pretty much the same thing so I'm just
going to copy and paste since we've
we've done it already
and instead of genre we're gonna do
faculty department for singular and then
departments for plural I'm gonna save
that hopefully that's all we need to do
it's worth a try at this point to see if
it works so we do need to copy all of
that and then add it in here to our
plugin so we'll go to our plugin editor
and let's go to what the plugin that we
made paste that in update it and let's
see hopefully I don't have to flush the
permalinks again we'll see if it works
like this if it doesn't then we'll flush
the permalinks it was a Oh
internal server error that is not good
Wow so we're not getting anything hmm
all right let's check this out I mean
we're still able to move around here
let's go let's let's flush our
permalinks
see if that makes a difference
all right so evidently I messed
something up
we shouldn't be surprising I do that
quite a bit also the stream is a little
bit earlier today so I can see I have a
lot less people going to normally have
let me know what you think about this
time though for a stream so I mean the
other time that we do this in the
afternoon well for me the afternoon is
okay with me but you know I'm interested
in seeing what time works better for you
also let me know either in a live chat
now or in the comments later on if a an
11:30 a.m. time is okay it it goes over
top of my lunch break but to be honest
with you I usually end up working
through my lunch break anyway so it
wouldn't be a big deal for me to stream
at this time if that ends up being a
better time for everyone
I can maybe try it out and just stream
at this sum of a few days and then at
the normal time a few other days a week
just to see you know how many people end
up watching hmm
I'm interested to see now okay so our
REST API is still working let's make
sure it's working here okay so the REST
API works maybe I do all right let's
take a look at what I did and perhaps I
I had it in an error well that's if it
was a syntax error in the plug-in then
we would get a much worse result
immediately right so we still have this
here so it's probably not a syntax error
but maybe I missed something so I'm
gonna bring this documentation back over
and we can look at it together
so okay we've done that we've added
those three attributes so these three
are the ones that are important and
we've also added them for the taxonomy
I'm not really sure what this is doing
or whether or not I need it let me
scroll up and see what else we have here
shushing
okay so these look like it's four fields
which I'm not worried about the fields
yet
but this is good to know that if we want
to add custom fields we can do that
yeah I don't think that first part is
what we're really going for right now
let me look more closely yeah really the
only thing that I didn't do was add this
in with the label see my labels look
different than their labels let's go
back and check what we have here so yeah
our labels were actually we've created a
variable labels and we have you know
quite a bit in here so let's compare
so I mean we have faculty right
[Music]
she's
all right let me check the live chat and
see oh hey Jason's here alright awesome
I'm really glad so jason created WP
graph QL the plugin so I'm really glad
that you that you came I um I was hoping
that you might you know stop in for a
bit so Jason I have the latest version
of WP graph QL installed in in WordPress
here so it's I think it's point 2 2 and
right now I've I've added in I'll show
you here so I've added in the show and
graph QL graph QL names right here for
the post type and then also for the
taxonomy but now I am getting an error
so when I try to get anything from graph
QL now well let's just try post again so
before when I try to get posts it worked
now I'm getting internal server error
what I'm really trying to get is faculty
and that's a custom post type so this is
the message I'm getting so I messed
something up and I'll leave I'll leave
this code up here with it we that we had
let me make that a bit bigger so anyway
so if you have any ideas about what I'm
doing wrong or anything let me know I
did use a show again what was I using I
was using the graph QL wiki page on
extending and customizing so that's
where I was going off of to do this
okay Jason is gonna try to get a snippet
for us thank you I appreciate it
okay so while we're waiting on that I'm
gonna check out what's in the live chat
as well here so it looks like it's not
it's not a bad time this so I asked
earlier about this time whether this
would work for everyone and seems like
the time is okay
all right so Jason's asking if the
faculty post type shows up in the admin
panel and it does so we have it here I'm
gonna refresh everything yep yeah so the
faculty post type does show up
okay it looks like so far I'm seeing all
positive response to streaming at this
time so yeah maybe I'll try it out I
think I said we have it's still lower
than normal viewers but that could
definitely be because I I scheduled the
stream you know kind of later like
pretty close to when the stream is
actually going to start and every time I
do that I always have less viewers I
think at least for some people there's
no notification usually there's like a
warning notification of the streams
going to start I'm gonna check to see if
I got it
yeah see I only got the notification
saying the stream is live I didn't get
the other one that I'd normally get
saying the stream is going to start in
30 minutes alright okay cool and Jason
has a snippet coming all right I need to
keep an eye on my time as well so don't
miss my Christmas party I had I was
already late to one meeting this morning
it snowed a lot here I mean a lot for my
area if you live you know farther north
than me it probably wouldn't seem like a
lot but I think it was maybe like two
inches overnight so anyway the kids had
a delay for school so it kind of threw
everything off this morning and I got in
a little bit later than I normally would
for my meeting so I don't want to be
late for two things in one day
all right let me we also have okay so
the the sights the react site the next
yeah site that we're working on have
some updates so hard [ __ ] went in and
and hooked up Apollo so that we can use
graph QL and pull the data in so you can
check out in the package.json I have up
here you can see there's a lot of new
things so make sure if if you've already
cloned this repo definitely do a get
pool I just added in yesterday I did
pull in those changes so I merged that
request so check that out so I mean
we'll be using it and going over it a
little bit more once we get graph QL
working here so I guess you can you can
check that out while we're trying to fix
this if you want okay won't let Jason
paste the code in the live chat let's
see Jason do you think yeah a harsh
desist try paste paste mental work if
you can paste it in a direct message on
Twitter that would work too whatever is
whatever is easier for you I think we do
have we do have this as a as a git repo
it's a public git repo so you could
paste it in an issue if you wanted I
mean really any whatever is the easiest
way for you to get it to me is it's fine
with me
all right awesome so Jason has put it
into a gist and I'm gonna check that out
right now
alright awesome let me pull this over to
this screen so we can just check it out
okay so
all right let's see
okay so we action
okay so I would replace
absolutely didn't have the
okay so Jason was saying it might have
been an issue with having the graph QL
single and plural names the same but
actually it looks like it works Jason
say not sure what the difference between
my snippet and yours is alright let's
check it out let's check it out again
like the only thing custom fields is
included here I don't see what that
would have to do with anything the would
are there any issues with me having near
the rest api activated as well I saw
with the last route
yeah with the last release there was a
note about a conflict on custom post
types that have registered show and rest
true so it does say that version 2 to
our zero point zero point two two fixes
that I mean I could try to take this out
let's try to take this out and see and
we'll try to take it out here as well
take it out so we've taken out all the
rest stuff here which if we're going to
use the REST API to pull in data we're
gonna have to put that back in but at
least you know we'll test this out and
see if if that was an issue oh yeah okay
so let's go back to our plugins to the
editor and we'll update that right now
let's check this out hmm
so still getting the error there let me
try the permalinks thing here again
mmm still an error just to make sure I'm
trying to I'm getting the right thing
here
yeah we should be able to get those Oh
what is this whoops
alright let me check
okay Jason says the show and wrestling
is working for for him so alright let me
let me just leave that back in there
since we'll probably need that at some
point anyway
okay harsh it says open the console to
see if there's an error in here for the
request okay yeah we have errors for
sure
yeah
so it's giving us a 500 internal
okay so it's it's saying the graph QL
requests must be a post or get request
with a valid query alright so let's try
hard refresh then
hmm so we're not we're not getting any
schema
oops my the timer went off let me do it
sure I think I'm all caught up in the
live chat let me double check but I
think we can just kind of keep going
okay yeah I've gone over everything live
chat so I'm just gonna start another
Pomodoro Pomodoro session here all right
all right let's try got some some things
that were being put in the in the chat
for me to try
okay still getting that internal server
error can you share a link of the WP
install yeah the the wordpress install
let me give you the link here I mean
it's just an IP address but there it is
in the in the live chat now okay so I'm
gonna take the snippet where to go
now I can't find too many things open
all right let's get rid of that I get
rid of that for now
there it is all right yeah so I'm gonna
copy this and let's yeah let's just put
this in here and then I'll take this and
comment this out
there we go
jace setup I'm like five minutes behind
on the stream that is that's a lot of a
lot behind I don't think I can do about
it now I usually do set it to low
latency so there's not that much of a
difference between what I'm saying and
when you all hear it let's see all right
so I'm just gonna try this and you know
what let me let me get rid of this for
now it's just in case that's messing
things up
okay so no more air so we have our post
again let's see if we can get faculty
what would we have as faculty members
yeah
oops I spelled it wrong yeah alright so
we have faculty members now okay so that
works so there's something in and what
I'm doing what I was doing that was
messing this up so
this weird
well alright I think we can figure this
out alright so I guess what we can do it
this is going to be kind of tedious so I
apologize for this but I don't know that
there's much sense in trying to move
forward until we make sure that this is
gonna work you know with everything that
we need so I'm gonna take basically I'm
gonna paste in these different things
let me see you know what let's try this
first all right so let's see if we can
get this taxonomy in here so basically
we're gonna slowly put paste these
things back in here and until we get an
error and then we should be able to find
out what exactly is causing the error so
this is going to be tedious just because
of the way I'm updating this plugin
which I wonder like actually I could do
this in a way that would be easier but
I'd have to set that up as well and at
this point I don't think it would be
worth it to take the time to do it right
now but at some point maybe it would be
alright let's update that and check it
alright so we did get the internal
server error and all we added back in
was the stuff with this taxonomy alright
so you know what I'm gonna try let's
take this out
and I'm going to departments
I'm going to take that out so basically
this is going to be
everything that we originally had for
our post types I'm adding all this back
in but I'm taking out this part that we
know caused an error so we'll see we'll
see how this goes now
okay so the air is gone but we can't
find faculty members and that's because
we named it something different so
faculty okay great all right so this is
good this and this took a lot less time
than I thought so all of this worked
right so just adding the show and graph
QL stuff to what we had for the post
type works but for whatever reason
something we did here with the taxonomy
did not work so for now I guess we can
we can move on for now and get this data
in here yeah I said let's see what let's
see what else we can get I want to be
able to see is there a way I can get all
the fields that are available here I
don't know enough about this syntax
you can do like that no it's not gonna
work
all right so let's do the ID title to
recall a department all right so we
don't have that field I could see oh
okay all right sorry Jason I I wasn't
looking at the live chat so jason says
you can't have special characters like
faculty - departments so I'd have to
camelcase it awesome
okay
baby is so harsh it says the wp install
is redirecting this is what I get when I
mean obviously it shouldn't really show
anything okay
let's refresh alright great we've got
the schema now and it's hype ahead as
you read queries great all right so
let's let's go ahead and add in our what
we needed here for or is that here we go
so I'm gonna grab these again and this
time oops let's see if I can get it
right so I should be able to do this and
then change it to faculty departments
oops
supposed to be Department right whoops
there we go faculty department faculty
okay great all right let's try this out
now
see if we get it no the shadow refresh
okay all right let's see
with the ID let's see if we can get the
title can we get this name yeah see oh
nice
alright check that out okay so this is
what we're getting now so we get all our
faculty members alright so right now I'm
I'm not getting all the data we need but
we have the title and then we have on
our faculty departments and we have the
idea which we won't really need but we
can get the name of that faculty
department it's awesome awesome awesome
this is great and actually that's thanks
for mentioning like the reloading this
to get the schema because this
type-ahead you all probably can see it
is too small but you know being able to
go in here and type in you know
something like this I can immediately
see you know what what's available to me
so I mean that's that's really useful I
just want to see what has four count
seven seven nice the count might be
useful at some point really cool all
right all right see much time we have
okay we're not bad on time can
definitely finish out this Pomodoro
cycle and right now there's not a whole
lot in the live chat that I haven't
already addressed so maybe I don't know
if we can do a whole nother Pomodoro a
cycle but maybe so we'll see so let's go
in now and let's try to pool some of
this data in let's see how we're gonna
do okay so we'll make a page first and
Paige will have parameterised routing
we've done this before in previous
streams so we'll have some parameterised
routing and then if they go to the page
we should see what this is like let's
check the current site I'm jumping all
over the place sorry about this so I'm
going to check the current site to see
what the URL is or jason says my
connection is saw it sorry I wasn't able
to help more but I'm not really able to
even follow us oh no problem Jason you
you are super helpful there's no way I
would have made it we'll figure that out
on my own about the having a camel case
things so super super helpful thank you
so much
alright so I want to check the current
site to see what the URLs are for the
faculty page if I can match that URL
that would be awesome then users who
have something bookmarked or any links
you know from elsewhere that are trying
to link to that page they won't break so
let's check that out first and I don't
really even know how to get to there
let's see Department all right let's try
departments first and we'll just take
biology so we did import the biology
professors so let's see faculty and
let's read more I actually know this
doctor dr. Oskie he's a super nice guy I
played Lord of the Rings Trivial Pursuit
at his house before and his wife is
super super knowledgeable about Tolkien
stuff and she actually beat me and so I
was really impressed but they're really
nice people so it looks like this is
going to be perfect so I don't know if
you can see the URL through
small.i there we go hopefully you can
see that better now but it's just slash
faculty slash and then the the name so
it's jurasky slash there so it's last
name and then first name see i can get
that we got to figure out a way to to
get that last name first name in there
just right now we have that's going to
be the toughest part because i don't
have i don't think we have a piece of
data with that slug but let's let's see
if we can find it I'm really glad we
looked at this first let's go back to
let's go back to the Microsoft sequel
whatever this is called sequel operation
studio that I always forget what it is
so I want to go back and find all the
fields again so I can look through and
see if we can we have that data in any
of the fields
alright let me check this
okay so something's up with the stream
the stream is smearing that webpage
looks like a window crashed in Windows
XP and you moved it alright so maybe the
zoom probably on the wrong Network right
no no all right all right listen I'm
gonna change networks really quick so
the stream is gonna drop off and then
start up again so I'm warning everybody
now that this is gonna happen so it's
just going to be a just a second I need
to just set this other network is my
default Network from now on since I need
it to work on it all right
so I'm gonna do it okay so the stream
should be back up so let me run this
again come on
my
try to disconnect and reconnect
all right let me copy this
there we go oh all right okay so looks
like alright I'm back we still have the
same amount of viewers we have any left
so that was a lot better than last time
we lost half the viewers when I switch
networks okay it's actually really good
to know you can switch networks in the
middle of a stream and it still picks
right back up that's kind of cool
all right so here's what we're looking
for some data that has the last name of
the professor and a hyphen and then
first name you would think it would be
in here right let's see if not this
might be something that needs to be
manually put in and hopefully we can
figure out some way no it's not in here
that's not good that's not good at all
all right let's check
let's check the data that we have now
and see if it's in here somewhere
you know I don't see it in there
okay blue day says hello hey hey how's
it going thanks for watching Harshit
says Queen you give me an example slug
alright so let's see what are our slugs
right now
okay so right now we're impress is just
making the slugs like McKenna
dr. Kyle right so it's adding that
doctor in there because of the way it's
it's in here we don't want that we want
it just to be let me double check
actually so Derek Duras key is Duras key
- Derek right so let me so even though
the name that shows here and that we're
pulling as the title into WordPress is
dr. Derek jurasky the slug is just Eric
- röszke so I'm gonna paste that and you
can see in the live chat now let's find
another professor so let's see Kyle
McKenna and make sure yeah McKenna Kyle
okay so yes it's definitely different so
I guess here's what we can do this might
not be bad for most of these it seems
like if they have doctor it'll change
let's see what this one since this is a
priest let's see what the name ends up
alright so even for a priest is still
you learning - okay last and first name
so what if we just wrote some function
that checked and if it had a doctor in
it it stripped that out wolf it had
fathers ofr period or tio R which mean
it's third order regular that's the the
order of Franciscans that that run this
University we could strip that out maybe
we can do that yeah maybe we can do that
in our in our migrate Jas file yeah I'm
thinking we do that in the migrate Jas
file and then pull in see if we can
actually add slug like a custom slug
here which we should be able to check
and here see if we can add it
so here's we create a post yeah we can
add a slug so we can make a custom slug
which can just be our last name and
first name but what we'll do is we'll
pull out any commas and we'll pull out
doctor or any titles like that and we'll
make sure we'll insert a - and we'll
lowercase everything
see
okay heart should just put in some
things to split this so I think I might
be mistaken but I think we need to go
the other way so what I have is is this
so I have this as a string what I want
to get is the slug Duras key - Derek all
lowercase without the doctor so yeah so
I need to go the other way that's what
I'm thinking so regular expressions then
and rook and Hart shooters are talking
about regular expressions in the live
chat yeah that's going to be the way to
go let's let's see what I can do now
actually my timer ran out so let me
check what time it is it's not too bad
on time right now let me double check to
make sure I didn't get any messages that
need my attention before the party slack
there's nothing in slack and there's
nothing in my email okay so I should be
good to work on this well let me I'll
leave it up to you all so here's what
I'm thinking we could do I could
manually change the slug on some of them
and then go forward with trying to
actually pull the data in or we could
wait till tomorrow when we can actually
get the regular expressions or Harshit
is is going to work on writing a regular
expression when we can actually pull
this data and we'll probably delete what
we have and then pull the data and again
with the correct slug that'll be the
fastest way to do it and then we can go
ahead and create our template for the
faculty you know our page and basically
use it so that the URL will be the same
as it is in the current site where I
just lost it words yeah so the URL will
be the same as we have in the current
site it'll be
you know a Franciscan dot edu slash
faculty slash and then faculty lastname
firstname and then based on that slug
that faculty lastname firstname then
it'll get the data for that particularly
fact particular faculty member C so
anyway so that's the two choices could
should we just use some manual test data
and keep going or should we just say
forget it let's just wait till tomorrow
when we can have all the real data so
I'll wait for some responses here and
while I'm doing that I just want to
check out what we have here already and
our pages so we do have a faculty page
already and
let's find our survey s faculty okay so
we have it set up already great that's
great so we have the parameterize
routing set up already so if you can let
me a lost it here we go so already when
it's slash faculty slash and then this
is going to be ID this we're calling it
ID but we know that's it's going to be
the slug we're gonna send the slug there
and we're gonna be able to access this
ID at that page so let's go back to our
faculty component and this query this ID
will get saved into props now what we'll
do is in this within this get initial
props we're gonna actually grab the data
so right now we're just returning the ID
but what we'll do is like we did on
project one the catechetical Institute
project here in this get initial props
function that's where we're going to get
the data and this will run server side
as well
so this will work with our server-side
rendering and then based on the data we
return then we can fill out the fields
here so this is actually gonna have for
now I'm going to leave this as ID but
really this will be the title so what
we'll have is that title we're gonna
have an image and then we'll have some
some text here so I mean really this
page is pretty it's it's going to be
somewhat close to what we what we want
but first let's let's just do kind of
like a demo here what's what it's gonna
be like so right now here's the local
version of this and I'm gonna go faculty
and then let's go to Ross key Derek
great see so Duras key Derek will be
able to access that and then use this
slug to access the the data so in graph
QL it would be
we essentially we would search by slug I
guess faculty I remember how I did this
originally but essentially here it would
be where slug why is it not giving me
slow
we're faculty
I don't remember I got it before but
basically it'll be like where the slug
for this faculty equals and then
whatever the value of that idea is so
that would end up being you know how we
get that data we pass in that ID and
then we pull it out which I can't
remember I can't remember how we did
that I'll have to check and see how
we're already doing that in that were
doing that in the bulletin the react
version of the bulletin we're doing a
similar thing so I can just check that
code out and github and I'm gonna do the
same thing that we were doing before
kiss your ass
hi should i watch the whole series from
the beginning to get along I wouldn't
try to watch the whole series from the
beginning I think we're well over a
hundred videos now it would take a
really long time
but maybe to get up to date as soon as
you can on on this particular project
maybe just watch all the videos that are
labeled with project five so if you go
back to like project five day one and I
think this is day 12 that'll be a lot
easier to catch up and then if I make
reference to some earlier project and
you want to you know catch up on that
you could certainly try to go back to
you know watch you know a video or two
from a previous project but I wouldn't
unless you have the time I wouldn't
worry about needing to watch every video
just maybe if you see a topic that that
interests you that you want to know more
about you know check that out but
otherwise it is it would take quite a
while all right
okay well I think at this point then
I think we'll end this this dream and
tomorrow will be kind of like part two
so we didn't we didn't actually get to
the point where we're pulling this data
into react but we are able to pull it
out of WordPress so we've got the first
part done the second part will be
getting the data into react and we
already have it set up we have our
parameterize drowning setup as we just
saw you know that works
it's just now we'll have to make sure
that we we call within this get initial
props function we're gonna pass through
that slug and get the correct data and
then we can populate this so that's what
we'll work on tomorrow and we may even
pull in the data from our sequel server
database into WordPress a little
differently so we have correct slugs
that's something I might work on you
know kind of earlier in the stream we'll
see how it goes but I think tomorrow I'm
gonna check my calendar just to be sure
that I'll be able to stream tomorrow
yeah I don't have any meetings on my
calendar tomorrow so I should be able to
stream I don't know about I might try
doing it at like the normal time that I
usually stream tomorrow and just see the
difference and in viewers but yeah but
that's it that's it for today so it
didn't get everything done that I
thought it was kind of an ambitious
project for one stream especially a
stream where I knew I had to end you
know somewhat you know if I could have
taken another hour I think we could
definitely could get it done but anyway
still we made good progress so even
overcame some
some issues that were mainly just based
on you know the fact that we had the
camel case things in our plug-in let's
see
boxing expert says good job Jesse it
takes true will to be doing this every
day thanks I appreciate that and then
thanks for watching
alright so I'm gonna end things now will
most likely be back tomorrow thank you
so much for watching and for all your
help
and it was really cool so I know Jason
who's the creator of WP graph QL plug-in
if you end up watching this recording
and seeing this then thank you so much
again
that was super helpful and and everyone
else who helped I really appreciate that
thanks hardship for the updates with
graph QL and our what are we calling
this franciscan site react project and
also thank you for for your your work
that you're about to do here on these
regular expressions so really appreciate
it and I'll see y'all tomorrow
have a great day